how much how do you get up for that kind
of a performance is it like 65 cups of
coffee
what do you do before you hit the stage
cuz that's the energy you gave up
Microsoft that's the energy you give the
Clippers how do you do that
iced tea iced tea iced tea iced tea iced
tea
okay the drink you don't listen to his
music he just like you got it never
happy all right you know what's funny
you look at these clips and then I find
out that as a kid you were very shy and
I find that almost like you had to have
had some kind of a brain operation to
change your personality that much how do
you go from a shy kid to someone who can
go out in front of people and do that
well probably slowly yeah is the truth
but the defining thing for me when I was
in college I was the manager for the
football team mm-hmm not a respected
lofty position but the manager had to
get up in front of the team every day
and say hey listen up a minute I've got
announcements my voice cracked the first
time that's my voice now actually that's
how I talk now at the end of two seasons
I got so I could actually talk in front
of a hundred guys who didn't want to
listen to me
right and you learned how to project and
you learned how to like whip them up and
get them enthusiastic a little bit okay
it's an infectious energy let's look at
you at Clippers games because you're
you're all over the map on Clippers
games let's take a look
[Music]
I'm glad you did what you do you've done
what you've done but I wish you'd gone
into Family Therapy have a you have a
philosophy in life and your philosophy
in life you define in one word which is
hardcore absolutely okay what are we
talking about here with hardcore
hardcore can have many meanings it can
yeah we actually looked at using
hardcore as part of our you know kind of
slogan for this year it turns out that
when you you know search for it on the
Internet yeah I might say Bing it for
example others would say something else
but you're looking up on the Internet
you really don't like what you get back
but hardcore you really like what you
get back exactly the things on who you
are we're a family operation at the
Clippers yeah so all the way this is how
I watch porn
[Applause]
so hard but you're okay hardcore is your
philosophy can find what it means to you
passion mm-hmm commitment tenacity
sticking with things something knocks
you down you just get up and you keep
coming and coming and coming and writing
that's what I mean by it's their fault
we didn't do it
always blame the audience is what I
found to be true but also a lot of hand
motions - you got to be in pretty good
shape I mean you've got a you're you're
constantly gesticulating gyrating
throwing punches in the air I know I
keep looking at scale it doesn't say a
bit good shape but I'm working at it I'm
just wondering what it's like when you
have a nightmare and hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please